I think that one of the most interesting
themes in our research is that sometimes
here in the West we can become prisoners
of our own cliches as Jose and planning
said today or prisoners of our own false
dichotomies and so we sometimes look to
Muslim women and we ask the question do
you want rights or do you want religion
and and that's the best that I cotta me
what we find when we ask Muslim women
themselves what they in fact want the
answer is both and they see no
contradiction between the faith they
cherish and the rights they deserve and
I think that's one of the most important
findings is that we have to break out of
these constructed false dichotomies and
really get a much more nuanced
understanding of this population which
tells us that they admire much about the
West they they see no contradiction
between Islam and democracy or Islam and
women's rights but that these types of
things have to be have to grow out of
their own cultural context they cannot
be imposed from the outside I think that
there are definitely some ways that the
interpretation of Islam needs to change
and many would argue to become more true
to its spirit but what is Islam
essentially is really the the collective
understanding of its people of its
followers and and so that that piece of
human agency is very important and what
we what we find is that not only are the
majority of Muslims interpreting their
faith to be to offer a vision of gender
justice but that they
they are in many ways fighting for
gender justice through the framework of
their faith rather than outside of it